[Music]
thank you bertrand thank you everyone I
wanted to I wanted to emphasize first of all
a word it was the opening word
you beaded bertrand about it earlier but I
think it's somewhere
hallmark of this program which is which
is a rather quite unique program
today because we have to bring together a
thing body of a certain number of
large groups we have made a call for
expressions of interest  we opened
with the first ecosystem with a
group of two researchers today
thanks to you I have a
very, very strong signal that we are sending with a
second phase of opening
with the start-ups with you,
here you go  it is really this
opening that marks somewhere the
signature of those of this great program
and I hope that it will help us as
said as said mohamed delivered how
the commet there we promised in any case
it was a commitment  that we had taken
when setting up this second program and
we therefore held on to this  is already a first
element and then the second element on
which I wanted to insist was the
model finally the model of
collaboration that has been promoted since then we are going to
celebrate 10 years of systemic r&d
next year
and I have heard a lot of  words that
are dear to our hearts in what
you mentioned earlier you
talked a lot about use cases you
talked a lot about feedback
you talked a lot about
collaboration
and 7.7 contact surface  between
academic industrial start-ups it's
been ten years since freedom has been working with
a very wide variety of actors to
precisely, driven by use cases,
seek
industrialization capacities and allow
everyone to develop so me what
I  take away from this evening here it is
opening and then it is the fact that
the intuition we had when launching this
technological research institute
that we could create value for
the entire ecosystem  tem by bringing
together large groups of smes of
start-ups
here by making all this
diversity work
around used cases game
somewhere tonight it is also a
validation of this bet and I
thank you for coming  there you go thank you
very much openly thank you paul
[Applause]
[Music]